(intrepid pop music)
- My name is Danny Tomsett.
I'm the CEO and founder of FaceMe,
and FaceMe is a company that has built
the world-leading digital human platform,
which is all about creating
an emotional connection
in a digital world.
One of the challenges for customers,
particularly as they're
interacting more and more
on digital channels
and not with humans is,
"How do I know that you understand me?"
"How do you personalize
an experience to me?"
"How do we create better
man and machine interfaces,
because they're becoming such
a common part of our life?"
We've seen just this incredible response,
based on the fact that our face,
is probably the most universal interface
that's ever existed anyway.
So, it's been really interesting
just learning around how
people enjoy conversation.
How they actually...
create empathy themselves
for a digital human.
(intrepid pop music)
We're a startup company.
We provide this as a subscription,
and our whole vision is
around how making this
incredibly easy for any
organization to consume
and build experiences
using digital humans.
So as a global company
with global customers,
you know Cloud is supporting that need.
Both in the geographical sense,
and IBM Cloud helps us with that.
I believe that the interface
between man and machine
is gonna change dramatically.
In the next five to ten years,
you're gonna see they're more humanized
and more personalized than ever before.
That's what we're super excited about,
and that's our vision for the future.
(intrepid pop music)